[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde la laïcité a-t-elle réponse à
tout la laïcité est de tous les combats
politiques idéologiques socioculturel et
même religieux c'est devenu un mot
fourre-tout qui traduit d'abord le
malaise de la société française de son
école des services publics et autres
producteurs de bien commun partout où
s'exerce des discriminations et des
pressions des comportements très
singuliers qui remettent en cause le
vivre ensemble mais est-ce que le 30
janvisme par exemple la lutte contre le
conspirationnisme etc font cause commune
avec la laïcité si tout est laïque alors
qu'est-ce que la laïcité au début de la
laïcité disons à sa source il y a la
fameuse loi de 1905 qui établit une
liberté de conscience entre croyant et
non croyants la séparation de l'Église
et de l'État et le libre exercice des
cultes tout cela dans le respect de
ordre public mais d'interprétation on
interprétation et à l'aune d’événements
symboliques et tragiques on pense bien
sûr à la décapitation de l'enseignant
Samuel Paty le 16 octobre 2020 ou
auparavant l'affaire du foulard de Creil
la laïcité est devenue une sentinelle
démocratique un bouclier contre
l'islamisme radical le respect de la
liberté d'expression aviatiques
républicain de l'apprentissage de la
liberté de l'égalité de la fraternité
cette extension du domaine de la laïcité
renforce-t-elle sa prévenant
socioculturelle ou à contrario est-elle
le constat de l'affaissement du
politique et de la politique au profit
des communautarisme et d'un tenaille
identitaire c'est ce que nous allons
voir avec mes invités alors Yanis roder
vous êtes professeur d'histoire
directeur de l'observatoire de
l'éducation et de la fondation
progresse smile la chair je vous
présente vous êtes sociologue professeur
des universités directeur de
l'Observatoire du fait migratoire et de
l'asile à la Fondation Jean Jaurès
Laetitia straussbona vous êtes
rédactrice en chef et essayiste vous
êtes rédactrice en chef à L'Express et
Emmanuel Morel qui est avec nous en
visioconférence vous êtes député
européen fondateur de la gauche
républicaine et socialiste
[Musique]
alors commençons par la laïcité pour
tout la laïcité partout vous connaissez
tous le proverbe qui trop en brasse mal
étreint à faire de la laïcité un
bouclier contre tous les mots n'y a-t-il
pas un risque de confusion sociale et
d'inefficacité politique monsieur Morel
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
déjà je trouve que on a tendance ces
derniers temps à coller systématiquement
à la laïcité un adjectif on parle de
laïcité ouverte strict moderne inclusive
exigeante apaisée positive et la
première des choses c'est de dire que la
laïcité n'a pas besoin de d'adjectif
pour être défini elle vise tout
simplement à ce que la société politique
détermine ses propres règles sans se
référer à une réalité une vérité révélée
c'est-à-dire indépendamment des
préceptes d'une religion c'est ça en
réalité la laïcité au départ c'est une
société qui se veut émanciper de la
tutelle de tous les clergé là où vous
avez raison j'ai bien aimé votre votre
expression extension du domaine de la
laïcité c'est évidemment ce concept ce
principe a été pensé à la fin du 19e au
début du 20e siècle les choses ont
depuis beaucoup évolué et quand je
disais débarrasser de la tutelle de des
autorités ou des clergé bah c'est pas
que les religions ça peut être les
autorités du marché ça peut être
ce à quoi vous faisiez allusion les
communautarisme c'est vrai donc la
laïcité c'est un peu étendu mais ce qui
compte quand même c'est le principe de
base c'est à dire on sépare strictement
la politique de la religion et ça c'est
très important surtout en ces temps où
on a un regain quand même de la
religiosité dans les sociétés
occidentales et pas seulement
occidentale d'ailleurs alors qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez Yanis roder vous
partagez ce oui oui je partage je
partage ce qui vient d'être dit par
Emmanuel Morel je pense que en effet
voilà ce qui a été ce qui a été pensé
à partir de la Révolution française et
jusqu'à la fin du 19e siècle et la mise
en place de cette de cette loi de
Séparation des Églises de l'État est
toujours et toujours effectivement
aujourd'hui et c'est un vrai
vrai
à tout de la République française
d'avoir su justement mettre en oeuvre
cette double émancipation c'est donc
Emmanuel Mor
[Musique]
elle ne peut pas tout mais
ce n'est pas son rôle de de pourvoir à
tout ou d'essayer de de construire des
des solutions quasiment intemporelles et
universelles mais il est indéniable que
la laïcité à la française
est une donnée très très importante qui
est au fondement de de la société dans
laquelle nous vivons aujourd'hui
Laetitia Strauss bonne à rien une
question que je voudrais vous poser vous
vous avez fait un reportage à travers un
très beau livre de francs sur la France
vous avez rencontré beaucoup de français
ce qui vous ont beaucoup parlé de
laïcité où vous avez le sentiment que
c'est plutôt un concept dans les sénates
disons bien pensant et influents mais au
niveau des Français est-ce que vous
sentez vous avez senti la prévenance
l'importance de cette notion
je pense que la notion est déjà connue
depuis longtemps
elle est connue par tout le monde même
si tout le monde ne n'est pas forcément
capable de la définir
précisément elle fait partie de de
l'histoire française en fait la laïcité
c'est la sécularisation dans sa version
française la sécularisation qui est bien
le refus de l'intervention du religieux
en politique qui s'est passé à peu près
partout en Europe et aux États-Unis dans
des modalités à chaque fois différentes
après pour répondre aussi à la question
de que vous posez dans dans l'émission
je pense que on a tendance à brandir le
terme quand on ne sait pas quoi dire
d'autre et on pense que ça va être une
solution pour un certain nombre de de
difficultés qu'on peut rencontrer et
notamment le fait religieux qui connaît
en effet une nouvelle nouvelle jeunesse
en France notamment du fait de de la
présence de musulmans dans notre pays
moi ce qui me ce qui tend à me gêné dans
la conception française de la laïcité
c'est elle signifie parfois la
détestation du religieux où sont son
incompréhension sa mise à distance alors
je pense que à l'origine ça n'était pas
ça à l'origine c'était la neutralité de
l'État aujourd'hui dans le débat
français il y a beaucoup de gens qui
brandissent la laïcité simplement parce
qu'ils sont ils sont anti religieux et
en France je constate qu'il y a souvent
une méconnaissance du fait religieux qui
est assez peu enseigné en fait à l'école
or à mon avis on peut pas comprendre la
laïcité et la sécularisation si on ne
comprend pas ce qu'est la religion et
pourquoi nos sociétés ont évolué de
façon à mettre à distance la religion
on va parler de la religion et on va
même parler du fait religieux mais
restons si vous voulez quelques instants
sur la laïcité et ses problèmes dans la
société française
et notamment dans le domaine de l'école
est-ce que vous pourriez dire monsieur
roder ce qui relève
d'un engagement laïque à l'école
parce que c'est une vraie question on en
parle sans plus qu'à l'école de l'école
laïque est républicaine alors c'est quoi
un engagement laïque en engagement
laïque de qui des enseignants des
enseignants des enseigner les
enseignants vous savez de
l'administration voilà alors si on parle
d'administration des enseignants
laïque alors on ne va pas à l'école avec
un engagement laïque on est
fonctionnaire de la République à partir
du moment où les fonctionnaires
République on se doit d'être neutre
voilà c'est ce que dit c'est ce que dit
la loi de 1905 les si vous êtes neutres
les élèves doivent être neutres non ce
n'est pas ce que dit la loi alors les
élèves n'ont pas à être neutres les
élèves peuvent exprimer oralement et
aussi par des signes discrets leur
conviction parfois même leur
appartenance religieuse s'il le souhaite
il y a pas de neutralité de nos
enseignants peuvent le faire aussi ça
mais non les enseignants eux se do
d'être neutre parce que l'idée si vous
voulez qu'il y a derrière cette
neutralité de l'État c'est que chaque
personne qui qui se trouve en face d'un
fonctionnaire doit être traité de la
même manière que qu'un autre et qu'un
fonctionnait on n'a pas à tenir compte
mais il ne doit pas montrer de signe pas
un problème d'appartenir est-ce qu'il y
a pas un problème à dire qu'on est
neutre prenez par exemple dans la
sexualité il y a des hommes des femmes
maintenant on considère qu'il y a une
troisième catégorie le sexe neutre
est-ce que vis-à-vis des élèves ou quand
vous dites je suis neutre vous pensez
qu'ils acceptent cette chose là ils
n'ont pas le choix en réalité on peut
voilà un fonctionnaire doit être neutre
c'est axiologique cette cette neutralité
du fonctionnaire donc il y a pas je
crois pas qu'il y a discuté là-dessus
maintenant qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
l'école laïque et bien ça veut dire que
le temps de l'école chaque je ne parle
pas des fonctionnaires je parle là des
élèves parce que ils vont à l'école
laïque chaque élève met en suspens le
temps le temps de
l'école ces appartenances première pour
se mettre en situation de recevoir les
enseignements qui vont lui être
prodigués ces enseignements et c'est là
où se situe la laïcité dans
l'enseignement donc la laïcisation de
l'enseignement ces enseignements ils
vont ils vont reposer sur la raison et
sur la science une vérité alors Monsieur
Morel vous en tant que député vous
considérez que vous devez être neutre en
tant que député
neutre du point de vue de la laïcité
je suis un parlementaire laïque c'est à
dire que je ne fais pas état de mes
éventuelles convictions mais ça va pas
de soi parce que moi je suis
parlementaire européen donc ça ne va pas
du tout de soi au niveau européen comme
vous le savez vous l'avez d'ailleurs
bien dit la laïcité à la française ce
que nous nous chérissons et que nous
considérons que comme une condition en
réalité de du vouloir vivre ensemble ça
ne va pas de soi dans les autres pays
européens vous avez des pays où il y a
des religions d'état vous avez des pays
où les cultes sont subventionnés et vous
avez des pays où il est tout à fait
normal que des élus affichent leur
conviction religieuses
participent à des cérémonies religieuses
etc c'est pas le cas en France et je me
réjouis je voudrais juste réagir à ce
qu'a dit Madame à l'instant parce que je
crois que précisément voilà il est bon
de rappeler que en aucun cas la laïcité
ne suppose l'hostilité de la République
envers les religieux mais pas non plus
la négation du fait social religieux je
crois qu'au contraire c'est très
important d'apprendre et de savoir qu'il
existe différents cultes différentes
histoires et culture mais je crains
quand même que le problème aujourd'hui
ne soit pas que la laïcité soit
instrumentalisée contre les religions
c'est surtout qu'il y a de plus en plus
de religieux qui mettent à mal et qui
conteste le principe de la laïcité et
pas seulement les fondamentalistes
islamiques comme on le dit parfois il y
a d'autres aujourd'hui il y a les
charismatiques les évangélistes certains
catholiques intégristes et d'autres qui
sont combattent la laïcité et c'est en
ça à mon avis qu'il faut absolument la
défendre dernière chose sur l'école
stress très important évidemment je
reviens pas sur ce qui a été dit je le
partage mais quand même ce qu'il faut
bien dire c'est que là aussi on a une
forme d'offensive
contre l'école laïque alors il y a des
exemples dramatiques vous y avez fait
allusion mais au-delà de ça il savais
pas que de façon insidieuse on remet en
cause des enseignements qui sont fondés
oui c'est vrai sur la science sur la
raison et qui part définition ne
reconnaissent aucun dogme ou aucune
vérité dites révélée ça c'est très
important parce que évidemment il en va
de de ce qu'est le rôle même de l'école
c'est à dire former des citoyens
éclairés dans la liberté absolue de
conscience donc là il y a besoin d'une
vigilance
et c'est pour ça que moi je j'ai une
conception quand même militante de la
laïcité c'est pas pas passive en aucun
cas au style aux religieux mais quand
même de rappel d'un certain nombre de
principes qui pour moi sont la condition
même du vivre ensemble parce que
précisément vous dites laïcité à la
française vous avez raison nous nous ne
sommes pas comme les anglo-saxons qui
considèrent que la société c'est une
juxtaposition de communauté la France
est construite différemment la
République s'est construite différemment
je pense que c'est bien qu'on le
rappelle aujourd'hui oui
chair oui je voudrais juste faire trois
remarques
la première c'est celle concernant
ce que peuvent penser ou ce que pensent
les Français de la laïcité
d'abord les Français c'est un terme
beaucoup trop général je ne sais pas de
qui on parle quand on parle des Français
est-ce que on parle des patrons du CAC
40 est-ce qu'on parle des des
ingénieurs est-ce qu'on parle des femmes
donc je ne sais pas ce que c'est mais si
je devais avoir recours à mon expérience
personnelle je suis sociologue donc je
fais du terrain depuis les années 80 et
il y a eu une époque où on ne parlait
pas de laïcité où il n'était pas
question de de laïcité ou ou la laïcité
n'était pas un enjeu politique
où la laïcité n'est pas un principe de
division entre entre les Français
même auprès des étrangers même auprès de
gens que l'on qualifie des migré ou
d'enfants d'immigrés c'est après les
années après les années 80 et je pense
qu'il y a eu un tournant c'est 2001 et
et c'est ce qui s'est passé aux
États-Unis en 2001 c'est d'ailleurs à ce
moment-là qu'on a vu pour la première
fois en France
autant de de Coran partir dans les
librairies bon le deuxième point c'est
c'est le le la place et le statut de la
religion dans une société or nous sommes
en France une histoire très particulière
de ce point de vue là et
je pense que
la laïcité c'est d'abord
et avant tout fondamentalement la
liberté de croire ou de ne pas croire
bon
et on demanda à l'état la plus grande
neutralité en fait l'état est agnostique
l'État ne sait pas ce que c'est qu'une
croyance il n'a pas à croire ou à faire
croire
telle ou telle dogme religieux
le dernier point c'est
à propos de de la laïcité et de l'école
bon c'est c'est un thème extrêmement
important alors moi je n'emploie pas la
notion d'offensive parce que l'offensive
c'est
c'est quand même une configuration très
très particulière ce sont des stratégies
qui sont pensées c'est des modalités
d'envahissement de l'espace
d'institution je dirais pas jusque là en
revanche aujourd'hui plus qu'hier la
question de la laïcité est un enjeu et
pas seulement pour
préciser ça pour noter les spectateurs
la question de la laïcité revient
très souvent par rapport à des problèmes
esthétiques si je puis dire rencontrer à
l'école est-ce que vous considérez que
les tenues certaines tenues
vestimentaires
avons un dérapage quelque part induisent
un dérapage religieux ou c'est
simplement une conduite esthétique non
mais alors ça dépend de quel vêtement
vous parlez il a il faut être là il faut
être extrêmement précis et je vous
laisse alors dire de
si vous parlez du dernier vêtement qui a
fait l'objet de par exemple de
polémique bon je crois qu'il est
inutile de faire preuve d'hypocrisie
collective ou de mensonge à soi le le ce
vêtement
la Bayard est un vêtement dont la
signification fondamentale est une
signification
religieuse c'est pas la peine de de se
mentir à soi-même le le le vêtement en
soit et pour soi peut ne pas avoir de
signification particulière mais là à
l'évidence il a une signification
particulière
la signification religieuse une
signification qui dit publiquement
l'appartenance à une vision du monde et
à une relation aux institutions que l'on
considère et je dis bien que l'on
considère comme des institutions qui
restent étrangères à la vision du monde
des gens qui portent cet habit qui qui
dit à haute et intelligible voix nous ne
sommes peut-être pas forcément pareil il
y a peut-être autre chose de plus
important de plus puissant au dessus de
la République et des lois de la
République mais en fait ce que vous la
dernière chose que vous venez de dire
est très intéressante et certainement
chez les musulmans aujourd'hui en France
il y a différentes attitudes il y a
cette attitude et puis il y a chez
d'autres une étude beaucoup plus
séculières ce que j'essayais de dire
tout à l'heure qui a peut-être été mal
compris van monsieur le député c'est
aussi que face à des visions du monde
comme celle que vous décrivez la réponse
n'est pas de dire c'est la laïcité point
parce que ça ne marchera pas
mon idée c'est de dire que face à des
gens qui sont vraiment convaincus par
l'importance de la religion qui pourrait
qui pourrait même plus importante que
tout le reste il faut s'y prendre
peut-être
un peu différemment je crois pas que la
confrontation avec l'imposition de la
laïcité fonctionne je pense que ça prend
du temps et qui faut vraiment expliquer
ce que c'est et par ailleurs la question
se pose aussi
j'ai l'impression qu'on se met pas dans
la tête de ces personnes quand ces
personnes sont confrontées à nous qui
sommes très laïques et parfois
totalement sans aucune religion et pour
qu'il christianisme aussi n'a plus
d'importance il peut y avoir chez eux
aussi un sentiment de d'étrangeté aussi
ou de d'incompréhension face à une
culture ou la religion
et quand même moins importante même dans
la sphère privée donc la question que
nous pose laïcité à mon avis aussi c'est
qu'en est-il d'un pays où le
christianisme n'a plus du tout la place
qu'il avait enfin pour moi ce sont des
questions qui nous sont posées aussi à
nous
Yanis roder
un petit peu ce que disait smile lacher
sur la question de l'offensive parce que
si ma mémoire ne me fait pas défaut le
journal votre journal L'Express je crois
avait sorti une note des services alors
je sais plus quel service qui justement
montrait qu'il y avait sur les réseaux
sociaux une offensive et qui était
vraiment calculée a priori parce que on
retrouvait des éléments de langage aussi
bien à Toulouse à Grenoble ou à Lille
porté par des jeunes filles pour
justifier le port ce dont vous parliez
ce mail la chair de ses abaya donc s'il
y a éléments de langage
identique à droite à gauche c'est qu'il
y a quelque part quelques voilà quelque
chose qui derrière voilà sans vouloir
tomber dans le complotisme mais qui
voilà qui qui tire quelque part les
ficelles et qui en tout cas cherche à
instrumentaliser les revendications
identitaires ou communautaires de ces
jeunes ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième chose
pour pour continuer dans ce que dans ce
que vous disiez il a évidemment un
effort de pédagogie à faire sur la
laïcité je rejoins là tout à fait ce que
disait Smain cher Mona Ozou vous disait
dans un livre en 1982 voilà laïcité
c'est réglé tout le monde est d'accord
même les catholiques voilà bon dix ans
plus tard boom donc on est plus du tout
enfin 10 ans plus tard c'est après
l'affaire de Creil en 89 en réalité ou
qui il y a eu des affaires du foulard
avant mais qui n'avaient pas ils étaient
qui n'avaient pas été publicité voilà
Creil c'est 89 donc c'est là on se
rencontre que non c'est pas si simple
que ça c'est pas accéder par tout le
monde et on sait très bien après que
voilà jusqu'à aujourd'hui nous avons
nous avons une vraie question qui nous
est posée il faut faire œuvre de
pédagogie en rappelant systématiquement
je crois cette idée de liberté justement
d'en parler smaïnacher là la laïcité il
faut la présenter de manière positive et
c'est vrai que les élèves la plupart du
temps quand vous demandez ce qu'elle a
la laïcité vous dire interdiction voilà
donc il faut il faut retourner la chose
ils annoncent pas interdiction liberté
voilà liberté liberté de conscience
liberté de culte et il faut le mettre
cela absolument en avant mais ça veut
dire qu'il faut former les enseignants
et il faut très bien les former monsieur
Morel je voudrais avec vous
évoquer une question qui fâche
est-ce que vous accordez du crédit
politique à la notion d'insécurité
culturelle évoquée par un républicain
Laurent Bouvet qui considère que
certains citoyens se considérant comme
des citoyennes de souches peuvent
ressentir une insécurité culturelle
quand il ne retrouve pas si vous voulez
leur précarité la France qui était la
leur idéale celle de leur grands-parents
etc
là on s'éloigne un tout petit peu du du
débat il se trouve que bon Laurent
Bouvet était un ami très cher et nous a
quitté hélas il y a maintenant plus d'un
an il avait forgé ce concept qui a
d'ailleurs fait beaucoup débats qui a
été contesté par un certain nombre de
collègues à lui mais je pense que leur
Bouvet était un observateur assez fin de
ce qui se passait dans la société et
justement je rebondis parce que je sur
l'histoire de l'offensive moi je
maintiens qu'il y a une offensive et que
cette offensive souvent
elle commence par l'école pourquoi parce
qu'il y a des courants religieux qui
sont des courants fondamentaliste
rigoristes qui vise à imposer une
certaine vision de la société et à
considérer que toute personne
supposément appartenant à leur
communauté doivent agir de la sorte donc
oui il y a du prosélytisme oui il y a
des provocations et oui nous devons nous
défendre non pas parce que la laïcité
serait quelque chose de violent ou
d'exclusion mais précisément c'est très
important ce qu'a dit Monsieur raudeur à
l'instant parce que nous nous défendons
la liberté et la liberté c'est la
liberté de croire mais c'est aussi la
liberté de ne pas croire et moi je veux
la liberté pour les incroyants pour les
agnostiques est-ce qu'il y a est-ce
qu'il y a ce prosélytisme au sein du
Parlement européen
oui alors nous avons été confrontés en
effet à plusieurs cas d'abord vous avez
le prosélytisme traditionnel des
catholiques notamment qui viennent de
l'Est je pense vous voyez bien la
Pologne et d'autres pays pour qui
l'Europe n'est que chrétienne en réalité
et donc il y a il y a des tentatives
répétées pour un pour imposer une vision
totalement univoque de l'Union
européenne dont le seul héritage
chrétien mais vous avez aussi plus
récemment des institutions européennes
qui sous prétexte de valoriser la
diversité au sein de l'Union européenne
ce sont mis à faire de la publicité pour
le port du jab par exemple avec une
campagne qui a été financée par le
Conseil de l'Europe qui disait la beauté
dans le hijab la liberté dans le hijab
que nous avons contesté également nous
députés européens parce que justement
nous voulons une société qui reconnaît
évidemment le fait religieux la
diversité culturelle mais qui ne fasse
pas de publicité pour une fois ou pour
une autre fois est-ce que vous
considérez que la corruption financière
évoquée dernièrement est aussi une
atteinte à la laïcité
ou alors là vous faites allusion au
catarget c'est à dire qu'il y a des
allégations très graves à l'encontre de
collègues qui se qui auraient été
corrompus par par le Qatar je vais vous
dire la vérité là bon c'est déjà une
affaire de gros sous mais quand même là
où vous avez peut-être raison c'est que
le Qatar a une stratégie politique très
sophistiquée
au sein du monde occidental qui consiste
bien sûr à financer un certain nombre de
structures acheter un certain nombre
d'institutions de clubs de football etc
etc pour faire aussi la promotion
d'une certaine idée de la foi et en
l'occurrence une idée très rigoriste
voire même agressive et je finis juste
un mot parce que je veux pas oublier sur
sur l'école et sur parce que Madame
stroogenard disait il faut pas donner
l'impression
aux croyants et notamment les jeunes
Condé dans le dans le mépris ou dans ou
dans le dénigrement je suis je partage
tout à fait cet avis mais il faut quand
même faire preuve d'un minimum de
pédagogie de rappeler au sein de l'école
que la foi ne saurait prévaloir sur le
savoir pourquoi je dis ça parce que et
ça c'est un phénomène nouveau
on est quand même obligé de rappeler un
certain nombre de choses scientifiques
et rationnel le monde n'a pas été créé
en 7 jours Adam et Eve ne sont pas nos
arrières grands-parents la terre n'est
pas plate etc etc pourquoi je dis ça
pourquoi je dis ça c'est pas oui non
mais parce que à la faveur des réseaux
sociaux des fake news et aussi de la
prégnonce de de certaines idéologies
religieuses on en revient à remettre en
cause des choses quand même
fondamentales dans l'apprentissage du
savoir donc forcément il faut se
défendre et forcément il faut se
défendre quand il y a une offensive
c'est ce que nous faisons toutes et tous
et c'est pour ça je crois que les
Français sont quand même attachés à la
laïcité
bon c'est un petit peu exagéré parce que
j'ai pas vraiment
défendu la lecture religieuse de la
création du monde mais c'est le cas dans
tous les ça ne dépend pas que du modèle
laïque dans tous les pays
occidentaux et plein d'autres pays on
apprend fait la différence entre la
science la raison et la foi là je veux
dire on va le sujet n'est pas et voilà
en voilà un exemple où on est en train
de demander à la laïcité quelque chose
qui n'est pas qui n'est peut-être pas
son rôle là le la distinction entre la
science et la et la foi il me semble que
elle est elle est de l'ordre de la
sécularisation qui est un phénomène
populaire
simplement pour vous dire que si c'est
pour aborder les questions religieuses
on va les aborder en deuxième partie
mais je vous laisse c'est je ne voulais
pas aborder la question de la religion
d'abord parce que j'ai pas de
compétences particulières les temps pas
théologiens et n'ayant pas fait d'études
de théologie ils vont une société où
tout le monde s'exprime surtout
en revanche en revanche ce qui ce qui me
semble important c'est c'est cette
notion d'offensive
c'est une notion importante parce que
elle a des effets performatifs
les mots leur importance
je
récuse totalement mais je je
suis très prudent sur la notion parce
que l'offensive l'offensive pardon
suggère qu'il y a un bastion à prendre
bon or je suis pas sûr que
il y a un bastion à prendre et puis et
alors là je je fais le sociologue je
voudrais voir je voudrais savoir dans
quel établissements il y a ce type de de
pratique
ce type de conduite qui est un qui est
une conduite de confrontation est
affrontement à l'égard de l'institution
scolaire où se trouve ces établissements
qui porte cette tabaya d'où viennent les
gens qui portent cette abeille est-ce
que c'est une immigration récente est-ce
que c'est une vieille immigration bon
franchement personne ne le sait pour le
moment parce que tout le monde est
focalisé sur le vêtement bon mais la
dimension sociologique le vêtement
recontextualisé l'histoire de ce
vêtement pas en l'air pas c'est pas une
histoire stratosphérique c'est une
histoire
qui a qui a un sens parmi les
populations qui
qui
pense que cette à baillade doit
[Musique]
être vu par tout le monde quel que soit
le lieu quel que soit
l'institution donc il faut voir de plus
près et je voudrais juste préciser que
en tout cas pour ce que je sais donc
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas un savoir
c'est pas un savoir qui ne peut pas être
remis en cause mais les jeunes femmes
qui portent
cette tabaya sont des des jeunes filles
qui sont nées en France
ils sont nés en France donc et
d'ailleurs peut-être peut-être
sont-elles même en désaccord avec les
parents bon ça non plus on ne le sait
pas mais
ils ne viennent pas d'un autre pays ils
ne sont pas issus d'un autre continent
et surtout surtout il faut être sérieux
quand on parle de ces choses là
je défie quiconque de me dire
que les jeunes femmes qui portent la
Baya a une quelconque culture religieuse
et je suis intimement persuadé que le ce
savoir approximatif ce savoir totalement
bricolé ce savoir Haddock pour pour
faire face à l'institution en fait c'est
de la deuxième troisième ou quatrième
main de Jean qui effectivement
là peuvent y voir une manière d'entrer
dans une institution très importante
pour récupérer des gens qui incarnent
l'avenir et donc ils sont pas dans une
offensive à l'égard de l'institution
scolaire ils sont dans des stratégies
c'est pas des stratégies dans des
tactiques de petits pas pour conquérir
le plus d'espace possible dans la
société
[Musique]
alors écoutez on va maintenant rentrer
de plain-pied dans les relations entre
laïcité et religion en France d'après
les statistiques actuelles mais qui sont
valables pour les 10 dernières années on
considère qu'il y a à peu près 37 à 40 %
de croyances moins de non-croyants
31%, 15% d'agnostique
bon ces chiffres varient un peu mais il
y a quand même une stabilité comment
faire pour assurer une présence du
religieux sans porter atteinte à la
laïcité et au regard du fait que
l'enseignement des faits religieux qui a
été prôné n'est pas une réussite
Laetitia je trouve Bona vous répondez en
partie à la question moi je pense que
l'enseignement du fait religieux devrait
être
plus importantes moi dans mon cursus
scolaire qui n'est pas si loin que ça je
n'ai je n'ai rien appris sur la religion
et je le regrette parce que
ce sont des fêtes civilisation et on ne
peut pas considérer que des milliers et
des milliers d'années
de vie humaine avec une forte pratique
religieuse ne représente rien même si
aujourd'hui nous nous sommes très loin
en fait de tout ça pour différentes
raisons donc je pense qu'on devrait
avoir une attitude un petit peu plus
humble vis-à-vis de du film religieux et
je le dis moi-même sans être pratiquante
ou affilié à on peut pratiquant
rassurez-vous si vous l'étiez vous
seriez pas excommunié de ce plateau ce
que je veux dire c'est que je ne défends
pas ma paroisse en l'occurrence mais le
fait religieux a beaucoup pas nous
apprendre notamment parce que dans les
textes religieux il y a quand même
il y a des éléments de sagesse aussi qui
n'ont pas disparu de nos sociétés on n'a
pas le monde ne sait n'a pas recommencé
au moment des lumières et d'ailleurs
même selon certains philosophes les
lumières peut-être n'auraient pas existé
sans
et bien des éléments religieux notamment
le christianisme parce que déjà dans le
christianisme vous trouvez
la racine de la sécularisation c'est à
dire la séparation entre
l'État le public et le privé donc ça ce
sont des choses passionnantes qu'on
n'apprend pas forcément parce qu'on a
peur de la religion on a peur de en
France un peu la religion alors monsieur
vous êtes enseignant est-ce que vous
arrivez à enseigner
les versets du Talmud les radits du
Coran les évangiles est-ce que vous
arrivez à le faire d'une manière laïque
alors vous savez quel sens ça et comment
faut-il s'y prendre je n'ai pas en tant
que fonctionnaire de la République je
dois suivre les programmes scolaires les
programmes scolaires ne me demandent pas
d'enseigner
ce que dit le Talmud ce que dit le Coran
ou ce que disent les évangiles en
revanche tous ces ouvrages peuvent être
des sources et sont vues et utilisés
comme des sources à l'instar d'autres
Monsieur Robert quand vous parlez de je
prends de certains préceptes tu ne
tueras point tu aimeras ton prochain
comme toi-même tu vas tu pratiqueras la
charité etc
ça quand même un substrat religieux
est-ce que vous l'évoquez quand vous
leur enseignez ces choses-là
vous savez
je crois et c'est très important d'abord
que il faut absolument
recontextualiser ces histoires là il
faut les remettre dans le contexte
historique et à partir du moment où on
ne remet dans le contexte historique on
peut aborder ces questions là en disant
là ce livre dit cela voilà ce que cela
signifie pour ceux qui adhèrent à cela
mais vous devez vous mettre vous en
retrait et avoir cette position on va
dire scientifique ce regard qui se veut
un regard objectif et distancié ça c'est
absolument absolument essentiel donc moi
je crois qu'on peut tout enseigner à
partir du moment où vous avez cette
attitude là et c'est ce qu'on demande un
enseignant c'est cette distance 16
distanciation et cette neutralité
vis-à-vis du discours qu'il vient de
lire voilà ça c'est extrêmement
important mais je voudrais revenir sur
quelque chose moi ce qui me semble
important aujourd'hui
c'est que nous avons un corps enseignant
qui en grande partie en tout cas dans
l'enseignement public et très détaché de
ces questions religieuses et
parce qu'ils sont passés par la même
école que Madame ces enseignants et bien
souvent n'ont jamais entendu parler de
religion et de ce que cela signifie et
donc ne parfois ont du mal à comprendre
ce que ce que peut avoir de profond la
foi et de Fort c'est-à-dire de dynamique
qu'elle peut porter et ça c'est il y a
quelque chose qui se passe parfois dans
les classes qui une espèce de finalement
de confrontation qui peut rester apaisé
mais d'incompréhension voilà quand on
quand on a un regard quand on a un
regard sur une religion qui ou c'est sur
la croyance manière générale qui est un
regard un peu exotique si vous voulez
qu'il me regarde ça un petit peu au côté
exotique quoi ils croient encore voilà
c'est ça arrive c'est comme ça ben on a
du mal à comprendre ce que disent
certains élèves et ce à quoi ils
s'attachent et ça je crois que c'est un
vrai problème d'où l'intérêt me
semble-t-il
de penser un véritable enseignement
laïque des faits religieux ça veut dire
quoi mais je dis en 30 secondes ça veut
dire quel comment quels sont les visions
du monde qui qui préside assez sur terre
quand on nous enseigne l'économie par
exemple
on peut avoir un enseignant qui est
marxiste ou libéral et on s'interroge
pas si les marxistes ou libéral je
pensais qu'on s'interroge pas vous
pensez que les élèves ne s'interrogent
pas
je vous pose la question pourquoi c'est
plus difficile avec la religion on a
peur des religions mais pour ce que je
vous je viens de vous dire je pense
qu'il y a une grande ignorance dans le
corps enseignant alors je généralise je
ne devrais pas bien sûr le sociologue
qui est ce mail la chair de comprend que
voilà il faut pas généraliser évidemment
mais bon d'une manière générale quand
même vous me permettrez de penser que le
corps enseignant dans le public dans
l'école publique est très élevé ces
questions là et donc du coup il y a une
gêne il y a une gêne il y a peut-être
une une insécurité intellectuelle quand
on aborde ces questions là d'autant plus
que vous avez parfois des élèves en face
qui peuvent être vindicatifs ça arrive
Emmanuel Morel l'a dit et je suis assez
d'accord avec ça donc voilà il y a une
une
un malaise un malaise et donc il y
aurait un gros travail de formation à
faire sur ces questions alors après sur
la question de l'économie voilà c'est
c'est il y a moins d'enjeux on va dire
c'est pas parce que enfin vous avez on
n'a pas on a on a assassiné vous l'avez
dit on avait on a décapité on a
assassiné décapité un enseignant sur des
questions religieuses pas sur des
questions économiques donc les enjeux
sont pas les mêmes ecoute monsieur
Spider on va laisser l'école de côté et
je voudrais interroger peut-être le
juriste que vous êtes sur un point
précis
concernant
la liberté d'expression la liberté
d'expression c'est un principe
révolutionnaire qui date de pub avant la
loi sur la laïcité est-ce que vous
considérez que par exemple à l'Assemblée
nationale dans les débats quand on se
jette plus que des noms d'oiseaux quand
il y a des dérives verbales
est-ce que c'est quand il y a d'autres
dérives verbales sur les sur les réseaux
sociaux est-ce que ça ce sont des
atteintes à la laïcité puisque tout est
mis sous le couvert d'une défense de la
laïcité oui alors je pourrai des pour
des raisons de méthode je sais pas quand
même l'Assemblée nationale des réseaux
sociaux je suppose qu'on n'y dit pas la
même chose que les débats ne sont pas
organisés de la même manière et on ne se
lâche pas de la même manière à
l'Assemblée nationale que sur que sur
les réseaux sociaux moi je pense qu'on
peut tout dire
dès lors que ce qui est dit n'est pas un
discours qui appelle à la haine et n'est
pas un discours qui trouble l'ordre
public
c'est pas un principe général ça peut
être un principe ça peut être un
principe qu'on fait sien et et et qui
peut produire des des effets
d'autocensure
je n'insulte pas je n'insulte si j'étais
député je n'insulte pas quelqu'un sur
parce qu'il a une couleur de peau qui
serait différente de la mienne je
n'insulte pas quelqu'un parce qu'il fait
partie des 89 députés du Front National
et voyez-vous
alors je le dis c'est même public
si on vient de serrer la main si
quelqu'un du Front national vient de
serrer la main je lui refuserai pas ma
main parce que une main qui est donnée
c'est une main qui est désarmée c'est
une main qui n'a pas d'armes et et donc
je vois pas pourquoi je refuserais je
refuserai de lui serrer la main même si
on ne va pas dîner ensemble et même si
on ne prend pas le café ensemble donc la
liberté d'expression et quelque chose
d'extrêmement précieux d'extrêmement
précieux que l'on peut remettre en cause
à chaque moment c'est quelque chose qui
a été douloureusement vous êtes vous
dites vous êtes pour la liberté
d'expression jusqu'au droit au blasphème
alors absolument vraiment alors là sans
aucune hésitation possible et je dis
même que on peut offenser des croyances
où on peut je mais mettons de côté le
mot offensé on peut critiquer
radicalement les croyances les dogmes
certains considèrent que c'est un
trouble à l'ordre public non non
critiquer la religion n'est pas un
trouble à l'ordre public à ce moment-là
à ce moment-là vous supprimez Charlie
Hebdo non non le le
blasphème et si je puis dire si je puis
m'exprimer ainsi et blasphévatoire si on
s'en prend aux personnes c'est-à-dire
aux croyants mais si on s'en prend au
dogme si la critique s'exerce et se
déploie à l'égard des des dogmes à
l'égard des croyances à l'égard des
visions du monde il n'y a pas de on vous
a entendu alors Monsieur Morel je sais
que vous voulez intervenir là-dessus
mais je voudrais ajouter une question
parce que ça nous permettrait d'avancer
dans le débat l'intolérance religieuse
conduit à la répression de jeunes femmes
en Afghanistan et au meurtre
en Iran
ou des gens sont assassinés quelquefois
sauvagement et on pourrait considérer
c'est ce que nous considérons comme des
crimes d'État est-ce qu'à votre avis ça
justifie un droit et un devoir
international d'ingérence
oh là là ça c'est une très vaste
question qu'on ne réglerons pas en 5
minutes en tout cas ce qui est le point
de vue du législateur que vous êtes est
intéressant et important puisque vous
êtes à la fois un législateur et avec
une casquette européenne
le législateur considère qu'il faut
sanctionner et sanctionner durement les
pays qui se livrent de tels agissements
et d'ailleurs ce qui est fait à
l'encontre de l'Iran mais aussi de
l'Afghanistan avec le retour des
talibans donc à la fois sanction et puis
soutien soutien à la sable aux femmes et
aux hommes parce que en Iran c'est
quelque chose de formidable c'est que la
mobilisation des femmes est soutenue
massivement par les jeunes hommes qui au
péril de leur vie parce qu'on parle
d'une jeunesse qui est martyrisée qui
est opprimée défend le droit de vivre
libre donc ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième chose vous avez dit droit au
blasphème mais en France il n'y a pas de
droit au blasphème tout simplement parce
que le blasphème ça n'existe pas
la loi française ne reconnaît pas le
blasphème justement parce que nous
sommes en état laïc et liberté de croire
et pas croire il y a pas de religion
d'État donc il y a pas de blasphème mais
s'il y a bien une tradition française
qu'il faut perpétuer et qu'il faut
chérir c'est le droit à l'irrévérence
la satyre à la critique fut-elle
radicale des dogmes des religions et des
clergé enfin justement si on a été aussi
nombreux à se mobiliser au moment du
drame de Charlie Hebdo c'est parce qu'il
y avait quelque chose parce que je pense
que les assassins avaient aussi touché
quelque chose de spécifiquement français
qui date de très loin Voltaire et même
avant jusqu'à Rabelais qui consiste à
moquer parfois les dogmes et ceux qui
les process enfin dernière chose parce
que je pense c'est une question très
importante moi je crois en effet qu'il
faut enseigner le fer religieux comme on
enseigne tous les récits fondateurs des
civilisations c'est très important de
connaître la Bible comme c'est très
important de connaître Homer pour une
raison simple aussi c'est qu'à partir du
moment où s'ouvre ou au monde de l'art
la peinture la littérature la musique il
est bien sûr que on va retrouver des
éléments de la Bible du nouveau de
l'Ancien Testament on peut pas
comprendre moi je suis par exemple un
fanatique de Jean-Sébastien Bach
Jean-Sébastien Bach et petrite que tu
religieuse je suis pas Nicolas Poussin
en peinture c'est pareil c'est bien donc
de connaître
les dogmes qui ont inspiré des oeuvres
mais tout en ayant et là je rejoins
totalement monsieur roder ce qu'il a
appelé je crois un regard objectif est
distancier et c'est là que c'est parfois
compliqué et je reviens encore une fois
ce matin rouge Bouchard qui va croire
que je veux absolument
débattre avec elle ce n'est pas vrai
mais elle dit si on sait foi le débat le
débat est réglé depuis longtemps mais ce
n'est pas vrai et aujourd'hui cela va
pas de soi je vais vous prendre un pays
qui est spécialisme d'une forme de
relativisme c'est les États-Unis
d'Amérique que nous connaissons bien ou
certains états aujourd'hui ne tolèrent
pas qu'on enseigne
qu'on enseigne certains certaines choses
en biologie et en histoire au nom de au
nom du créationnisme donc c'est un je
m'excuse mais c'est un combat qui est
encore d'actualité
j'ai pas du tout dit que elle va vous
répondre
des créations
mais qui nie aussi des vérités
scientifiques au nom l'idéologie donc je
suis d'accord je pense qu'on doit pas
nier les vérités scientifiques au nom
des idéologies ça c'est sûr
c'est que ça n'est pas propre à la
laïcité de vouloir séparer la science et
la foi
et j'ajouterai et j'ajouterai aussi que
mais alors peut-être ça va vous plaire
qu'il y a beaucoup de grands
scientifiques qui sont aussi très
croyants au sens où la séparation entre
science et foi elle se fait parfois à
l'intérieur des individus et c'est cette
complexité de l'être humain que je
trouve intéressante après vous me direz
c'est vrai que face à certaines
difficultés aujourd'hui on est très loin
de cet enjeu là et l'enjeu il est plus
simple enfin plus compliqué mais en même
temps plus simple qui est de dire bon
vous mettez la vous laissez la fois en
votre fort intérieur et vous apprenez la
science parce que c'est comme ça qu'on
que nos sociétés fonctionnent voilà mais
on n'est pas on n'est pas tellement des
accords je voulais juste mais c'est très
court je voulais juste
rectifier
au plus exactement précisé ce que ce que
j'avais dit tout à l'heure sur la
question du blasphème en fait la
question du blasphème ou le problème du
blasphème c'est d'abord un problème des
dévots c'est d'abord le problème des
dévots c'est pas du tout le problème des
des blasphémateurs c'est d'abord le
problème des gens qui se sentent
blasphème le monde évolue
il n'est pas dicté uniquement par
l'universalisme français on observe ce
communautarisme partout et on observe
une division du monde aujourd'hui entre
des pays autoritaires avec quelquefois
de véritables dictatures est-ce que à
votre avis au regard de cette évolution
stratégique socioculturelle la laïcité
française doit-elle rester immuable une
exception culturelle ou nécessitent
telle quelques adaptations Laetitia
stradona alors on a un peu de temps mais
c'est un peu votre la conclusion si vous
voulez qu'on voudrait dire donner voilà
mais j'ai du mal à voir en quoi la
laïcité doit être liée à des
problématiques internationales ce que
vous semblez relier les deux et dire oui
parce que la France est dans le monde
oui c'est
la culture est pas que française
des dictatures s'affirment aujourd'hui
qu'on a varié sur notre position sur la
laïcité il me semble on a déjà des
débats intérieurs suffisamment complexes
entre gens qui sont d'ailleurs plus ou
moins d'accord
enfin moi je vois pas forcément un enjeu
international dans à moins que j'ai mal
compris vous ne voyez pas la possibilité
de variation anthropologique en quelque
sorte par rapport à ce qui se passe dans
le monde aujourd'hui
ce qui est ce qui est vrai au niveau
international c'est qu'il y a une
pression notamment par l'intermédiaire
de la presse nord-américaine par exemple
sur la laïcité française et qui ne
comprend pas le je pense au Newton
Washington qui ne comprennent absolument
pas ce que veut dire laïcité française
et qui de fait défendent un autre modèle
culturel et donc par conséquent un autre
modèle politique mais moi je suis
d'accord avec ce que vous venez de dire
c'est à dire et alors et alors les
Américains ont le droit de penser ce
qu'ils veulent ils n'ont pas notre
histoire ils n'ont pas la profondeur de
notre histoire et ils n'ont pas notre
conception de de de républicaine c'est
une autre conception voilà nous nous
sommes construits sur cette idée sur
cette conception et dont au coeur de
laquelle nous trouvons la laïcité je ne
vois pas pourquoi parce que il se passe
des choses en Amérique du Nord où il y a
ou il se passe d'autres choses ailleurs
nous aurions à changer de ce modèle
voilà je pense que ce modèle il a fait
justement ses preuves nous vivons
jusqu'à preuve du contraire dans une
société beaucoup plus apaisée que la
société notamment nord-américaine et je
crois que la laïcité n'y est pas
étrangère
sur ce point si on reste dans le Nord
bien évidemment ces débats sont sont
importants et la question de
l'universalisation de l'universel
effectivement est un débat qui ne cesse
qui ne cesse de de de circuler dans les
pays du Nord mais si vous descendez
celle-ci vous allez dans les pays du Sud
bon et pour une une aire géopolitique au
culturelle que je connais un petit peu
qui est le monde arabe par exemple
la question dalaïcité
pour certains et pour de plus en plus de
personnes est un enjeu extrêmement
important je pense en particulier on
peut pas développer oui mais pourtant je
vous assure c'est important parce que
voyez-vous si on devait faire preuve de
solidarité par exemple avec
avec les Iraniens etc et bien il faut
penser que
dans ces pays-là pour certaines
fractions de ces populations
l'universel existe la laïcité peut
exister la laïcité c'est tout simplement
la dijoncture entre le temporel et
spirituel merci Monsieur Morel un point
qui vous voulez pour conclure sur
est-ce que ça doit rester immuable ou
vous qui êtes au contact de 27 voire
plus de pays européens
il y a quelque chose à bouger où ça doit
rester
d'abord j'abonde totalement dans le sens
de Monsieur la chair il se trouve je
suis président de la délégation Maghreb
au Parlement européen et je peux vous
dire pour bien fréquenter les sociétés
civiles des pays du Maghreb que la
question de la laïcité du rapport à la
religion
ne va pas de soi et qui a des gens
aujourd'hui qui se battent pour
conquérir ce type de droit mais je
finirai très simplement en reprenant ce
que vous avez dit vous avez parlé
d'universalisme et justement au moment
où se multiplient les différents
cialisme au moment où accroît parfois ce
qu'on appelle le relativisme il est bien
de redire que ça soit français ou non il
est bien de redire que il y a des
principes qui sont universels et ce que
nous prouve le combat des femmes
iraniennes par exemple c'est que oui il
y a des principes qui sont universels
qui valent partout dans le monde et pas
seulement sur tel ou telle territoire
déterminé et ça c'est une leçon
formidable parce que aujourd'hui
l'universalisme est contesté à droite
aussi parfois à gauche et ben il faut
qu'il y ait de plus en plus de gens qui
continu de défendre merci beaucoup alors
je dois vous présenter une brève
bibliographie
smile la chair vous avez publié
l'affaire Mila victime agresseur haine
en ligne à Fondation Jean Jaurès et lobe
je voudrais également signaler un autre
ouvrage que vous avez publié et qui
s'appelle juger la terreur le procès des
attentats de janvier 2015 à l'aube
Laetitia Strauss Bonnard nous avons déjà
présenté votre livre au cours d'une
émission précédente c'est en l'a évoqué
au cours de l'émission de la France
c'est à la fois édité par Perrin et
presse de la cité donc c'est j'allais
dire une balade enfin une balade
c'est une excursion quasiment
ethnologique et culturelle de ce que
sont les Français aujourd'hui alors je
voudrais
monsieur Yanis roder vous avez publié un
livre alors qui était dont on a beaucoup
parlé en tout cas au cours de cette
émission à savoir la jeunesse française
l'école et la République c'est le
témoignage de votre exercice
professionnel et c'est pas seulement le
témoignage c'est aussi une analyse de
beaucoup d'enquêtes sur ces questions là
c'est donc une analyse de beaucoup
d'enquêtes comme vous dites donc vous
voyez on part du particulier mais à
l'universel et je dois signaler aussi
puisqu'on a parlé de Laurent Bouvet
portrait d'un intellectuel engagé ça a
été publié aux éditions de
l'Observatoire monsieur Morel vous
voulez signaler un livre que je vous
avais publié plusieurs ouvrages qui sont
pas tout à fait dans le cadre de la
laïcité mais je vous laisse en signaler
un seul si vous voulez bien avant de
terminer cette émission
d'abord j'ai contribué au livre sur
Laurent Bouvet donc je vous recommande
vraiment ce livre j'y ai fait un long
article moi je vous recommander un livre
pratique ça s'appelle le maire et la
laïcité réponse pratique c'est un avocat
qui s'appelle Philippe Bluetooth qui est
très talentueux et qui répond à toutes
les questions pratiques que peuvent se
poser à la fois les élus mais aussi des
citoyens sur la laïcité au quotidien
c'est très bien fait et en plus tout un
rappel de la jurisprudence des
différentes juridictions administratives
merci beaucoup je voudrais remercier
madame messieurs d'avoir participé à
cette émission je voudrais remercier
l'équipe de LCP et avant de vous quitter
je voudrais vous laisser avec cette
pensée je voudrais rendre hommage ici à
Samuel Paty et donc je vous laisse avec
cette pensée c'est un débat essentiel de
convaincre la genèse de la puissance de
nos valeurs universelles et de la de la
laïcité synonyme de liberté l'enseignant
Samuel Paty est mort pour avoir défendu
cette liberté c'est une pensée une
citation de Manuel Valls
[Musique]